hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday
monday morning podcast and i'm just
checking in on you
that's all i'm doing nothing aggressive
today
just you know
just hanging out
um
hey i got a great way
do you hate your job people i'm gonna be
a bit of a pitch man today hey man do
you hate your job
do you go in there thinking if i have to
[__] walk through those goddamn doors
one more time i i think i'm gonna stick
my head through the plate glass window
like me back in the day when i said i'd
make a pie i rep
[__] stealing from my own act here
um
just tell people you have coveted
get yourself 10 days off
you know two of those will be a weekend
day
just tell people you have covert nobody
asks to see the test result
i can't come in i got covered you sound
all right yeah i'm asymptomatic but well
you better stay home and tell your
vlogger touch nugget all they want to
see is the negative test
stay the [__] home
so i just get back from uh from france
i guess covert
like hulk hogan's pet pythons are
running wild
what are you gonna do when covert comes
and gets you somebody told me hey if you
get it man
take uh they got a new drug out there
man it's called pax lovid
and i was like i'm not taking that [__]
and they said why not
i said because it rhymes with the
disease
it rhymes with the virus
i'm not [__] taking that [__]
you know got pneumonia take uh splavonia
wait a minute
my wife goes uh
she got shingles take pringles
why does it rhyme with the disease
well because it's a virus part of the
virus hospital those parts of the cure i
have no idea
but i was just thinking
you know
when i got the covid back in uh january
there
i
um
you know first of all i didn't even know
i [__] had it
that was a great thing as i didn't even
know i [__] had it
because i went out and and i got that
microchip shot into my body
by the way dude i don't think i've ever
gotten more goddamn [__] for some stupid
[__] stand-up thing than i did for
that netflix thing i hosted
good lord what a bunch of [__] babies
i talked about covet and written house
you'd think i [__] tore up the
decoration of independence
um
[__] unreal man
[__] unreal these people uh bill's a
[__] government shill
[__] whining goddamn babies man i you
know i i do love about the left and the
right aside from the fact that my fellow
countrymen
is
they just have no
[__] self-awareness
of
like how they everything that they say
they don't that the other side's doing
they're [__] doing both sides are
doing it
like
um you know in the 2000s what we'll just
do right now right now like the rebels
man
the people saying hey man [__] the
government man
this isn't what the founding fathers
were talking about man
that's the right
they're like [__] you government [__]
you
i'm not listening to you i don't trust
[__] you you want my guns come and get
them right they're doing that [__]
those same [__] [__] in the 2000s
when dumbass george bush
went ahead and bankrupted this [__]
country
by trying to shoehorn 911 into iraq he
they were like you know
he's he's [__] going like he has
weapon he has a weapons of mass
destruction and a nuclear [__]
whatever
program we got to go stop it andy was
part of 911 and i don't think he likes
my dad right
so then we [__] go in there
the guy's got nothing
and then it goes from uh we're stopping
him from that it goes to a liberation
it's like did you just change the
[__] mission like overnight
after you committed all of these these
lives and money over there
so liberals were going no
don't do that the government's full of
[__] they're slave to [__] oil
companies blah blah blah blah the same
[__] today who are going like uh [__]
the government
back in the 2000 like support the troops
america love it or leave it
he's got weapons of mass destruction
turns out he doesn't it's a liberation
same [__] people exact same [__]
people in my head they are right
and then
yeah the liberals
doing the whole hey it's my body it's my
choice [__] roe v wade my body my
choice
[__] vaccine comes out for covet
people don't want to take it like take
the [__] shot
[Laughter]
so i am evidently i've learned from this
this uh my last
two specials the special and then this
thing i hosted i'm somehow stuck in the
middle of these [__] they both
[__] can't stand me
oh god wait do you see my abortion bit
this is before roe v wade i got a
special coming out next week oh geez the
hairy-legged white chicks are coming
how can you [__] say that i knew you
like donald trump i'm gonna be getting
that
um
i don't know i i don't i don't know what
to tell you i guess because back in the
day i used to [__] go off on banks in
the federal reserves and all that type
of [__] and you know where that got me
do you know where that got me
it all it got me was meeting people like
that guy that had the buffalo horns on
that went into the [__] house of
representative senate whatever
the capitol building
that's all that that ends up with and
nobody gives a [__] and nobody's doing
anything so what was i gonna do i'm
gonna be the guy sitting there flapping
my arms with my head on fire i just said
[__] it
and you know what
kind of feels great
so i don't know what to tell you
all you federal reserve [__]
background i still agree with it i still
know it's a [__] ponzi scheme but i i
can't
i you know i i fought the good fight for
five years and then i just stopped it's
like right now everybody's [__] uh
you know
[__] blaming joe biden for the gas
prices and ignoring the fact my buddy
was just saying it's like dude they
[__] pumped like two trillion dollars
out of nowhere 20 trillion into the
economy there's going to be a inflation
i was actually saying like i feel like
the oil companies are trying to get back
all the money they didn't get in [__]
uh
in 2020 when people stayed home i don't
[__] know but anyways people stop
taking my [__] so goddamn seriously i'm
a [__] comedian
good lord
these [__] idiots you're a stand-up
comic they want you to be their their
[__]
i don't know what president
or or surgeon general
it's like no i'm neither one of those
things i'm a [__] [__] who tells
jokes all right so shut up all right
pax love it everybody
hey with the name with that rhymes with
covet it has to be good
[Laughter]
bold the cure for the common cold
prancer do you have cancer take prancer
um
i will not
see now look how dumb that is
just think about that i will not [__]
with a medicine if it rhymes with what
i'm trying to cure with cure all right
that's the level of intellect you're
dealing with here people
bunch of [__] babies you
conservatives you liberals you're all a
bunch of [__]
babies
it's the amount of [__] that's actually
[__] going on out there and these
[__] idiots
all they can do is go after a goddamn
you know stand-up comedy
yeah that's gonna change it
[Music]
as if what comics are saying is suddenly
becoming law
that's what i've always loved about that
because the reality is if stand-up
comedy did have that level of power it
wouldn't be legal they couldn't you
couldn't just have any jackass doing it
oh wait a minute any jackass can just go
in and buy a gun oh [__] now he's a
liberal again
um
hi i have a chicken on my head and i'm
wearing a diaper
how old are you i'm over 18. here you go
i don't know how it works okay people
i don't understand how it works um all i
know is i'm trying to get my my my son
has um
is uh we're reining him in and he's
understanding that the hammer's coming
down i did not like his behavior
in public at the hotel and stuff i've
realized that i've just been a little
too relaxed with him overcompensating
for the screaming and yelling that i i
grew up with so what i'm doing
now um
you know
he gets his little timeouts he has a
little chair and that's where it is and
it's amazing because i put him in the
[__] chair and he fights it for like
30 seconds and then he realizes that's
where he's gonna he's gonna be he
immediately stops crying the temper
tantrum's gone away and it's like oh
so it is just an act this is just a
manipulation thing my thing is i hear my
kids crying i just want it to stop
because
sorry i have an old science chair here
um
i just wanted to stop because
yeah you know
it's your kid crying it breaks your
[__] heart so i just have to push
past that
so
he is obsessed
with my car my old truck
so he starts going you just you'll go
down his car
he starts at that emotional level not
like that his car he goes dad his car
that his car
he starts pointing out so daddy's car
so every time i would be like all right
buddy all right let's go and i'd scoop
him up and i would take him out and i
put him in the driver's seat and it
started becoming like five six times a
day
and you know i have [__] to do here so
it's like
i kind of learned that if you give them
everything that they want the second
they want it
then they get this unrealistic uh idea i
know it kind of makes sense once you say
it out loud but so i'm trying to undo
that
um
but fortunately you know he's a smart
kid
a really smart kid so it
it was already taking
and he was already changing just with
one day of it
so
um it's kind of funny too to see him
sitting in the corner
he was sitting in the corner on this
little rocking chair that a buddy of
mine got him so he's sitting on the
thing
and um
he's just looking at me and i'm watching
tv
and he's being quiet he's sort of
rocking a little bit
and then i looked over him and he was
looking at me and i was trying to stare
at him doing the
i'm not happy with you right now
and he
i was staring at him and he stares back
at me
then he kind of did like half a smile
and i swear to god i think i took six
years off of my life trying not to smile
on that moment because i was trying to
make my point but you're smiling like
come on
hey dad it's me what are we doing here
let's go wrestle come on
um
my wife read somewhere you know whatever
their age is
that's how long you should do it for so
which is cool because he's only two
it's two minutes then he comes over and
he's all right but he's funny though
when you tell him like
try not to yell just do a like a firm
voice
and when i do that now
he does this thing where he puts his
hands over his eyes
and then he peeks through
and i was like and i'll be like yeah you
can't do that you have to be nice to
your sister you understand me and then
he he turns his head all the way around
like linda blair turns it like into the
couch so he won't be looking at you
so
it's a copycat league in the family
everybody so my wife was giving me [__]
about something that i was doing
probably interrupting her when she was
on the phone or some [__]
she started giving me [__] about it
when we were laying in bed and i just
turned my head all the way around into
the pillow
and she immediately went oh
are you sad
it's a dead-on impression of my son
speaking of my son and my lovely
daughter
um
we got a [__] coyote problem
i've had two or two different neighbors
tell me hey just to let you know
there's been some coyote
you know jumping over your poor excuse
for a fence into the [__] front yard
right
like all right
and they're like do you have a cat or
anything like that i'm like no it's not
our cat but a [__] just
every [__] animal just waltzes
through our goddamn yard right so this
is some they said it looked like an
adolescent coyote and it was
jumping over back and forth back and
forth over this thing so
um i don't know what i'm supposed to do
about that um
i'll be honest with you i hope it just
kills the cat
no more food here buddy shut down
another victim of covid it is just shut
down and that's all there is to it
see you later no food here or maybe i i
do one of my favorite things to do is to
take a garden hose and point it at a cat
um
because they're [__] and the water
doesn't hurt and it's just you know you
just sort of you put your thumb over the
nozzle
all right over the end
just give them a misting
they do that quick movement like what
the fact is it raining and then they
realize it's you and they [__] take
off it's like that's right
that's right the water man's here you
will respect me and my
alma said my hose that didn't sound
right
okay when bill was talking about the
cats that sounded a little rapey
um
how about those boston red sox huh
[__] unbelievable
we just can't seem to beat anybody in
the al east there i said it we had some
kid debuting last night i watched a
little bit of it between daddy's car
daddy's car
um
he sounds like he's in a horror movie
anyway i watched a little bit of that by
the time i turned it on it was four to
nothing in the third inning um
i want to say we came back and scored a
run or something but it didn't matter
um so now we got the yankees
we got the yankees so we'll see i don't
know it's just our uh
our pitching is decent the bats have
just been a little quiet lately
um we definitely
have to get going against stronger
rotations
gee you think so bill yeah i'm gonna go
i'm gonna [__]
i'm gonna go with that
that's gonna be my uh
my little solution
um
anyway i [__] crushed it coming home
though
as a dad
everybody was like all jet lagged and i
just i don't know i i kind of stayed up
oh i know i stayed up in the plane i
[__] drank like four cups of coffee
every time i would start to get sleepy i
was like nope not doing it
i will not fall asleep until 10 o'clock
this evening
west coast time and i was able to do it
and um
i got back acclimated and everybody else
has just kind of been [__] uh
you know jet lagged or whatever so i've
been just handling everything
[__] handling everything i like doing
that [__]
cleaning up washing dishes
you know giving the kids the baths just
[__] crushing it going out uh getting
the packages
huh going to cvs
you know
picking up whatever the [__] it is we
need and coming home bam bam bam
you know swinging by my
grocery store
getting my kid her favorite ice cream
just knocking it the [__] out
um
i've actually had a great couple days
since i've been back here in the united
states america
um
i got that new uh
that new porcupine tree
album
and uh
i broke down that whole first song now i
can't play a lot of the [__] that he's
playing but i at least know what the
band is doing
and i was able to figure out the second
half remember i was staying on the last
podcast if you didn't listen
yet that first song's in five and then
when they get to the chorus
they play
uh
three against four until beat four and
then he does a fill
on the end of four crashes on the one
and then it repeats
then there was this other
sort of uh i don't know what what the
musical term is for it uh
phrase or whatever that they play
towards the end of the song that was
really
really [__] me up
and i'm like what in the [__] are they
doing and i finally figured it out last
night um
they play three against four again
i don't know if it's in this bridge
section but it they do it
uh with eight eighth notes
so um they're doing hits every third
eighth eighth note so it's the one
and then the end of two
and then the four etc for three bars
before it comes back around to the one
um
like dude i'm gonna [__] sit down and
i'm gonna write this song out i'm gonna
get this [__] song down
i don't know why
probably because i have a bunch of other
[__] going on in my life and this is a
nice [__] distraction that this is
what i'm gonna do um
but the first one is three against four
uh counting in sixteenth notes so it's
one e and a two e end at three e end up
four e um
i don't know i feel like i just lost
everybody on the podcast except for
drummers and all the drummers are like
um that's not what he's doing
actually he's playing a herder
okay and he's playing it on the snare
between the snare and his right hand on
the floor tom that's what he's doing
and then he's playing a ghost note
with his left hand that comes off the
hi-hat pedal
and he has one of those
cowbells
um
i've been watching a bunch of those uh
a bunch of those drum videos and [__] i
really like the uh prague metal
stuff anybody got some good bands i can
listen to when it comes to that [__] i
know i know um
as far as just like the sickest medal
you're ever going to hear me sugar i
guess has a new [__] album
my drum teacher was telling me said just
it's insane
so if he says it's insane i know it's
insane so i got to get that but does
anybody just have like um
you know i can't listen to that right
right right about all the [__] time
you know
or maybe my ears just aren't like
accustomed to it yet like meshuggah's
like one of the few bands like that that
i can uh
i can listen to
um
like i don't know [__] about that kind
of metal
like i go like giant leaps
through decades it's like the 90s was
pantera
the 2000s was llama god
somewhere around there i've heard of
meshuggah and that's as far as i go
um
a little bit of slipknot
and now like i don't know i just been
getting into double bass again and i've
been watching um
people doing covers
of uh
some of their songs and beyond the drums
being unbelievable
is uh i actually am listening like i
[__] like that song
who knew the only thing is is when i put
that [__] on
my wife just looks at me like you know i
understand like
you know
it's a white person you play that around
a black person i think they oh god this
person's in a hate group
oh can you tell the gun not to [__]
turn the goddamn music down
um i told you guys when my f 250 gets
here i want to i want to write like
really like disgustingly liberal [__]
in the back window
to offset those people that write like
freedom and uh
whatever the [__] else they write back
there
that's like a big thing like i've
noticed that like for some reason people
with pickup trucks
they're the conservative version of
liberals with priuses like if there's a
prius you can
almost guarantee
well if you're going to hear somebody's
lefty political opinion it's going to be
on like a [__] prius right but if
you're going to hear somebody's right
oh my god this is a reality show
you know they're always like you know
sticking like opposite people you know
in the same [__] house
you take a [__]
bleeding heart liberal
you know what i mean
she has like a future the future is
feminine remember that stupid [__]
slogan
that's another thing that the classic
like hypocritical [__] on both sides
um as opposed to me who's in the middle
and is a perfect person
okay which is the only reason why i'm
attacking both sides this has nothing to
do with anything about me wanting the
country to be better and people to get
along this has to do with me
trying
to frame myself in a light that feeds my
ego
um
the future is feminine remember that
[__] it's just like uh
isn't that what you were just fighting
because the president is male
and you're saying this is oppressive so
how is if the future is female how is
that just not going to be the same thing
on the other side
and they were just like uh what uh
whatever trumpster
that conversation never happened it
happened in my head but that's what i
feel like they would say
um honesty
um
so you take one of those [__] idiots
one of those hairy like white chicks you
know that has it all figured out man
right
they're [__] you know
the rainbow flag bumper sticker the
future's feminine gender neutral
bathrooms
my leg hair my choice right you take
that person
my overgrown bush
my my lawn right
so
you stick her in the house and then you
just have some guy pull up in a pickup
truck
with freedom and
that one that one other guy said uh a
mask
has the same ability you know
a stopping the virus as your underpants
to have of stopping a fart or something
stupid like that i love how some egghead
wrote underneath that going like well
actually
um a fart is a gas where covet is a
solid that travels through water vapor
um
anyway that's another one that i like i
like how like the anti-massacres are
like going oh they didn't [__] work
all this [__] it's like first of all
you did not wear a mask because you knew
from day one that they didn't work i
love how everybody's acting like they're
this [__] scientist now
and now that they have the information
or whatever
they're saying they never [__] it's like
that's not why you didn't wear a mask
you didn't wear a mask because because
you felt it was coming from people that
wore blue ties
so you were like don't [__] tell my
freedom what to do
if george bush in 2001 told you to wear
a mask those same people be like
america wear it or leave it
and then the liberals would have been
like this is oppressive how can i talk
about gender-neutral bathrooms with a
mask on
um why can't you all be perfect like me
uh when will you guys understand that
i've figured out everything in my head
by talking to myself
and not reading books
um
i did read a i read a book this year
wilmington's lie you got to check that
one out which has now
gotten me like i want to read about the
1800s in this country and i don't want
to [__] read the [__] that i
already heard and when i when i was
coming up in uh school
when i was just a lad
right
way back when when i would finish
milking the cows and the goats
i would walk to school
run past uncle touchy's house um
i completely forgot the [__] i was
talking about
when i used to go to school
oh history class
i painted such a vivid picture i was
thinking about galway ireland
doing that irish little that portable
irish accent
and how they had like some [__]
goddamn place where they would send
non-married and pregnant
young women
to have their kids so they wouldn't
bring shame to their freckled family
and uh you know these nuns didn't know
what the [__] they were doing and a lot
of times the babies died and they just
[__] stuck him in this all the dead
babies they stuck them in this [__]
i don't know what
underground something and then one day
they just found them all
um
and you know the irish
they probably somehow found some humor
in it
right how many [__] dead babies does
it take to run a [__] um anyway
so when i was a kid when they would
teach
history every [__] year they would
start with columbus sailed the ocean
blue in 1492
and then somewhere they would get to the
declaration of independence
and that was it
that was [__] it and there was no
talk about slavery
there was no talk about anything maybe
we get into the
french and indian war
i think one time we got all the way up
to the uh war of 1812 but there was
nothing
about the civil war nothing about
slavery nothing about what we did to uh
indians native americans whatever the
[__] you're supposed to call them
um
whatever the proper
terminology is
um
so a long time ago i read that people's
history of the united states which was
just way on the other side
i was just like this is what really
happened man
george washington
everybody loves him
that guy had his [__] dick out man
the guy had his powdered wig on his
[__] dick going who's licking these
revolutionary nuts
that's what really happened man so that
was all the way to the other side
so i feel like i gotta like i don't know
read a little bit of both
you know
because it's kind of like a sporting
event
if your team if you listen to the
people's team that lost they're like
yeah the team cheated man
um i'm really oversimplifying all of
this so anyway i wrote i read that book
and in the book they said one of the
things that was scaring the hawaiians
was uh the nat turner uh slave revolt
so i was like i'm gonna [__] read a
book on that
um
i'm gonna [__] uh check that out
it already seems like it has a really
like the back story it's like a marvel
movie but it's too intense
it was basically
that when
nat turtle was a kid he saw
some white dude come in and rape his
mother
and then he just it was like the batman
story but with rape
and he was just like [__] all right
i'm oversimplified i'm going to read the
book
and then i'll give um i'll give you my
uh my version of it as i
there's that and then there's another
book i want to read jim cat
k-a-a-t
my eight decades in baseball i want to
read that one too
because i remember as a kid collecting
baseball cards and i had him his card
when he i think he was on the st louis
cardinals or something
or maybe the yankees i don't know but i
flipped the card over
and he had been in the league for so
damn long there was no room for any
information
uh of like where he went to college
where he played
you know
it was just
the smallest type i'd ever seen he
played in the 50s the 60s the 70s and
into the 80s
he had a 20-plus year career i think his
first year was 1959. i might have even
talked about this so i want to read that
one too so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to read like hardcore history
and then an athlete's autobiography
you know what i mean that's what i'm
doing to try to balance it out
all right because i kind of liked when i
was reading and i got away from my cell
phone
you know and i didn't keep getting that
message like
this is the most cell phone time you've
used
in the history of you using it it's just
like who is tracking this [__] who's
talking to me right now all right people
let's let's do a little advertising here
roman
you know when the moment for intimacy
arrives you want your dick standing up
just like george washington's was when
he was signing the declaration of
independence
uh you need to be roman ready uh whether
you've been in a relationship for years
or you're uh or are just getting started
having the confidence that comes from
preparation means you're free to enjoy
the moment when the moment comes
even though you are far from ordinary
the truth is that e.d erectile
dysfunction is really common in fact 52
percent of guys age 40 to 70. i love 70.
jesus christ if you can get out of bed
at 70 that's fine your [__] dick
supposed to be like who wants it
um 70 experience some form of
erectile dysfunction
go to get roman.com burn now to speak to
a u.s licensed healthcare professional
about erectile dysfunction and get 15
off your first month of treatment ed is
more common than most people think in
fact 52 of men between the ages of 40
and 70 will experience some form of
erectile dysfunction uh the benefits of
ed treatment can help you reconnect with
your partner and rediscover the joyous
sec reconnect with your partner how will
you look at that huh oh jimmy's back
uh roman ready is a confidence jimmy who
calls that dick jimmy
um some people call robbers jimmy gators
[__] wear
uh roman ready is confidence personified
it is the self-assurance that comes from
knowing you've prepared yourself for the
moment when intimacy arrives roman's
system is completely confidential and
totally discreet hey
i heard your dick doesn't work uh no big
logos or labels on packages with roman
you can get a free online evaluation
look at that penis and ongoing care for
erectile dysfunction all from the
comfort and privacy of your own home a
u.s licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan
if medication is appropriate
it ships to you free
uh with two days shipping the whole
process is straightforward convenient
and discreet getting started is simple
just go to getromand.com
and complete an online visit take care
of your erectile dysfunction without
leaving your home complete an online
visit today to connect with a u.s
licensed healthcare professional and
take care of it go to
getromand.com today and if you're
prescribed get 15 off your first month
of ed treatment make sure you're ready
to have confidence and control this
summer with roman ready
oh look who it is everybody
look who it is
it's all zip
[Music]
uh you know what i'm excited to travel
this summer i actually did i went to
france um have you ever thought about
all of the people that make a vacation
truly great
you know outstanding talent
i didn't finish that [__] story so
you take the [__] guy with the pickup
truck
and you put it with the [__] written all
over and you put him in a house with
some [__]
lady with the prius
you know or you have two guys
whatever you want to see happen and
maybe they can [__]
just scream about politics
and in the end
and in the end they find a middle ground
right
and then
now that would never happen
whoever makes it out of the house
um
i was gonna say without crying
if they cried
whoever cries first you know the liberal
would lose
it's got to be balanced you guys help me
flesh this out i'm going to i'm going to
pitch it to fx
all right zip recruiter you know i'm
excited to travel this summer
i really am you can hear my voice have
you ever thought about all the people
that make a vacation truly great you
know
outstanding talent is crucial for a
successful business
and if you're hiring you can find talent
for roles like those and more at zip
recruiter what have you ever thought
about all the people that make a
vacation truly great what does this have
to do with hiring employees
you know outstanding talent is crucial
for success for a successful business oh
i get it so then you'll have the money
to take a vacation
anyway if you're hiring you can find
talent for roles like these and more at
zip yeah
uh when you try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com zip recruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
i'm pointing in the air right now people
to try and make that point more succinct
[__] what is going on
my [__] throat is all dry this
morning uh you can easily review these
recommend oh i know i slept with the
[__] ac on
i just don't do well with that man
um you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply additionally zip
has a complete suite of tools
that makes it easy to filter review and
rate your candidates four to five
employees who post on zip
[Music]
load up
get a quality candidate within the first
day no wonder yes yes yes
that's the double version of it zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site based on g2 satisfaction ratings as
of january 1st 2022
so
travel to this easy to remember web
destination ziprecruiter.com
that's where you can try zip recruiter
for free again that's ziprecruited.com
uh spell out burr b-u-r-r zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire
that's my favorite part of any copy i
just love that little pause sip
recruiter
the smartest way to hire
um
i feel like i i informed the public
something about that that last line of
copy i really enjoyed oh look who it is
everybody simply safe
i'm using my simply safe to catch that
goddamn coyote
i'm gonna go on how to scare a coyote
out of your yard.net
all right simply safe today's episode of
the monday morning podcast is brought to
you by simply safe home security i
believe home should be the safest place
on earth for every family
well why can't we expand that to just
walking around in general we got to
bring back nut houses everybody uh
that's why i use and recommend simply
safe simply safe is advanced
whole home security that puts you and
your home and your family's safety first
here's why i love it simply safe offers
comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglary but
against expensive home hazards from
flooding to fires
gotta love that in la
no floods
oh you might have a mudslide
with 24 7 professional monitoring simply
safe's agent
agents take action the moment a threat
is detected dispatching police or first
responders in an emergency even if
you're not home simply safe uses
proprietary video ver verification
technology so that monitoring agents can
visually confirm the threat in order to
get higher priority 911 dispatch
monitoring plans are affordable priced
at a dollar a day with no long-term
contracts or hidden fees because feeling
safe at home shouldn't break the bank
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.comburr
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
the interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.comburr
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr
all right
and that's it people that is the monday
morning podcast now the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
um enjoy the music here and then uh
picked out by the uh always lovely
andrew themilis
um
and then we'll have a bonus episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday july 7th
2014.
how's it going how are you are you
driving to work
are you already at work you're in your
cubicle are you [__] off
are you bringing this country down by
not doing your share of the workload
today
well who gives a [__] if you work for
somebody else the [__] do you care
i mean whose dream is it really is it
yours i don't think it is it's not your
dream it's their dream
you know
what kind of office did you dream about
as a child you had a [__] door the
walls went all the way up to the ceiling
you know
you went in the middle of a [__] room
you know with a
four foot wall
surrounding you on three sides
completely vulnerable anybody who went
to west point can tell you right now
that that is not a safe position and
that you need to move
you mean you need to move to higher
ground
um i don't want to get involved in all
that crap it's a wonderful weekend the
july 4th weekend the celebration of the
independence
of uh this this wonderful nation did you
guys go to a parade
what did you do did you get hammered and
watch some fireworks
i actually one of my favorite things to
do out here in uh
in los angeles is on july 4th how
everybody just shoots fireworks wherever
the [__] they want to
and me and my wife and some friends
every year we just go up on the roof of
my house and we just sit there and we
watch and fortunately none of my
neighbors shoot any off it's always a
couple blocks away and then just all the
way across la and we just
just watch it i always try to take a
video but the cell phone
just doesn't it doesn't do it justice
and um and there's there's like a mall
i don't know how far away it is
say like i don't know three to five
miles away they actually have one so
right as we're getting on the roof
they're usually getting to their finale
because you know people bring their kids
to the mall
you know one of those [__] malls that
has like a trolley that drives around it
and they play like tony bennett and
sinatra and everybody feels like you
know like they're a winner
as they're walking in and out of the gap
luck be a lady tonight
never let her out of my sight
hey do you think these overalls look
good on me a lot why don't you put them
on you [__] tub of [__]
who is over law if you're not growing
food if you're wearing overalls if
you're not in an early 90s r b band
you're basically wearing it because
that's what your stomach feels
comfortable in
you know it's like
it's like you're pregnant as a guy
you have one of those you know those
satchels that people wear
you know where they one of those little
swath [__] whatever it is it's like a
blanket and it's like a paper root bag
at the same time and there's like a baby
in there
well the baby in this case is your big
[__] round stomach
you know i'm trying to fetch shame some
people come on people
make a quinoa salad i guess quinoa even
though it's spelt o-a is not the way to
say it some [__] [__] on twitter's
giving me [__] you're driving me crazy
it's pronounced quinoa what kind of a
man
knows how quinoa or quinoa is even
[__] pronounced
okay
you know what kind of man knows
something like that
besides an h f
is a [__]
somebody who's comfortable with
themselves
somebody who realizes
that meat is a lie
now i'm [__] with you
i've i'm actually i've really cut down
with my meat intake just out of pure
vanity i love it you don't eat meat your
[__] stomach goes away
the fat has nowhere to hide or as they
say in long island hide
it has nowhere to hide
um
if um
yeah it's got nowhere to [__] go
i i
cooked this weekend
like a a yoga instructor slash of fat
[__]
you know i made my
quinoa salad
quinoa how the [__] you say it i made
that thing which is great fills you up
like pancake batter you just pour it
down your gullet you're like i'm good
you know what's funny is they say it's a
complete protein but you can add chicken
to it in other words it's not a complete
protein
all right
all right there you with your [__]
stretchy pants and your bare feet stop
[__] saying it's a complete protein i
know it isn't
okay
and i made that and then uh i made this
peaches and beet salad with goat cheese
i said i don't give a [__] what you guys
say you can call me a [__]
douche all day long a [__] twinkle
toes i don't care
it's great fills me up and i wake up the
next morning and my [__] white
stomach's a little smaller
you know to try it
i actually went to the grocery store and
i bought
organic beets where it had like the
[__] leaves like some [__] just
[__] some migrant worker
you know because americans don't want
those jobs if we grew beets in this
country they'd be 40 dollars a beat
um
we actually had to pay people
and we still kept our yachts it would be
forty dollars a beat
um
can anybody explain to me the economics
of that why everything has to be done
outside of this country or it would be
nine zillion dollars and don't even
[__] just say it's because of the
unions i know it's partly because of
that
but the other part is those people with
those [__] yachts that i saw in
santro pay
in order for someone to get a boat that
[__] big legally
without being a [__] pirate there's
got to be somebody crying in a field in
el salvador pulling organic beets out of
the [__] ground or allegedly organic
beets out of the ground to the tune of
about eight pesos a [__] month
right
isn't that how it works
isn't that how it works i don't [__]
know
all i know is there's something going on
with all these gated communities
we live in a gated community what the
[__] are you doing
or what do you know that's gonna happen
all right there you you [__] uh
what do you call those guys that know
how to build [__]
freemason
i like how people get mad at freemasons
because they know how to make [__] and
they don't want to tell you about it you
know don't you have a secret recipe with
your barbecued ribs there you know or
your [__] cream pie or whatever the
hell you make don't isn't that a secret
family recipe
well the secret family recipe with the
freemasons is they understand how the
universe works
if they went and told you how the
universe works next thing you know
you're off the grid
you know growing apples in your toaster
you don't have to pay for electric power
why would you go to that cubicle with
your four-foot walls you wouldn't do it
and then what would they where would
their joy be
if they couldn't see you walking into a
[__] building every day that you
didn't want to go to where would their
joy be
what would fill up their dark souls
what misery could they look at
they would left to be tortured i guess
like torturing squirrels
on their property
right
you know what i want to do out here i
want to [__] go up to that i want to
go up to that hurst mansion
um
william randolph hearst whatever the
[__] his name was he's like the original
rupert murdoch
and he [__]
he owned all of this [__] why does verzi
always call when i'm doing the podcast
um
he's like the original uh
what the [__] rupert murdoch and he
owned [__] everything allegedly uh
citizen kane was about him but he has he
has the hearst castle
somewhere between here and san francisco
and uh it takes you like three days to
get through it this was the guy's
[__] house and i actually shot a uh a
scene one time not one time about him
last month who's kidding who
uh ozo did a sketch for kroll show i
might as well hype that i think nicole's
a [__] genius so i hope you guys
watch the next season i got to do a
little bit of acting work on that and uh
we shot in a building that used to be
owned
by uh william randolph hearst and
allegedly
big word allegedly
there was a secret elevator
in there
that old uh
oh billy uh not red face used to bring
up his uh
extracurriculars in
you know
with the [__]
louboutins or whatever [__] his [__]
horse he had a [__] elevator
that's when you know you got money
you know out of all those mtv cribs and
shaq with this giant [__] bed
right and [__] red man with people
sleeping on the floor of his [__]
place you never saw anybody with a
horror elevator
to this day
you know
it's [__] brilliant
the [__] elevator
when the [__] was the elevator invented
that seems like some early 1900s
possibly
late 1800s
type of [__] you know
you know in the late 1800s when they
first came up with that they probably
had like [__] six-year-olds pulling
people up in it it was completely legal
um
but anyways this guy had a [__]
elevator so i mean if he had a [__]
elevator at [__] work i'm not gonna
look at his house
i gotta do it
um
so anyways i've been off since i did my
special and uh i actually got i'm
finally gonna sit down and watch it
tonight
i made the lovely nia promise me that
you sit down and watch with me because
you know it's not it's a [__] outer
body experience
all right
it's one thing to take a video and look
at it you know
of yourself doing something dumb that's
one thing but to know that a bunch of
people are going to [__] see the
thing then that really makes you
makes you a little bit nuts
you know so i got all my other busy work
out of the [__] way it's why i'm
doing the podcast here sunday night
and um because i know i got to get this
[__] 800 pound gorilla off my
shoulders i got to sit down and watch
i gotta watch the [__] thing which i
don't wanna do
um
oh god i'm dreading that
anyways uh
the [__] was i talking about so i'm
really enjoying just you know last
since i got back from vegas
just not doing [__] i didn't do [__]
all week
other than uh
make my [__] twinkle toe stuff oh and
then i also i made this [__] dessert
i just love when you guys trash me for
whatever i do
uh
i made this chocolate chip cheesecake
with a chocolate crust
and i can't even tell you guys how
ridiculously excited i was to make my
first like
look like a brownie crust and i was
always wondering how the [__] do you
make the crust
how do you get the chocolate in there
it's just like this cocoa powder you put
a little bit in there and then you sift
the [__] thing down right you put in
your [__] shortening
i overcooked it
i could how do you tell it's getting
golden brown when it's chocolate
you know
i don't [__] get it anyways
so i ate one of those things today and i
feel sick
it's too much
you know
[__] too much what am i talking about
i don't know what i'm talking about i'm
on [__] vacation i'm living in my own
goddamn world out here
so uh other than that yeah i was uh i
was hiking with my dog all this week
we're still getting the work done in the
house and i had the dog uh she stays at
the vet during the day because she gets
freaked out
when the workers are making all that
goddamn noise
and um
so you know i was on the road getting
ready to do the special i hadn't seen
her in like a week and i came back and
she was [__] fat
made a fat pit bull
they love her over the vet and she loves
them my dog loves anybody that takes
care of her first she's like who the
[__] are you and then the second you
take care of her she turns into a little
lap dog
and uh so they love her to death so
they're always giving her treats and i
[__] see her i almost didn't
recognize her
you know what i mean you like when you
go to your high school reunion after 20
years you really got you got to kind of
look just like a little part of the
forehead and the eyes
is where you can still see the person
that you used to know
and um
that's what i was doing so i went on a
bunch of long hikes with my dog
fortunately she's a pit bull so she's
all my muscles and she's back in shape
after like three four days
and that was uh basically my weekend
and um oh i forgot to mention so we
ended up going up on the roof
to uh to watch the [__] fireworks
and uh
so we go up there and everybody's
shooting them off and everything and
every year i say and i go you know it's
[__] amazing
that all these people just randomly sh
and this there's some people they're
shooting off some real [__]
not just like bottle rockets they're
shooting up stuff that blows up
and shoots out into like a ball
you know and it usually happens you know
i don't know
two 300 feet up off the ground they
shoot them up and it goes off at like 75
feet off the [__] ground in between
these apartment buildings so i'm
standing on the roof
and i'm literally saying
to my wife i go you know it's
unbelievable every year how all of these
things get shut off and nobody lights
their house on fire and within [__]
two minutes of me saying that
um
i look in the distance and i'm thinking
like wow that that
firework is is lasting pretty long and i
look at it and has that undeniable
orange glow slash dancing of fire
and i'm like that's a fire
somebody let that [__] house on fire
right and i look and sure enough
i couldn't believe how fast it spread
and next thing you know there's a
helicopter flying around it and then you
know
off to the left we hear the fire engine
starting to come down and as fast
as that thing lit
ignited and as fast as it spread they
[__] put that thing out
i'm sure they you know drowned
everything that anybody owned in the
building
but uh they put it out pretty goddamn
quick
and uh so i got video of it i don't know
i mean maybe i'll put it up there i was
actually talking to verzi when i was on
the phone i think i was him that i said
maybe i'll up whatever i'll post the
video um
it's not but i you know i'm not gonna
post it because it's not a good video
you know this [__] cell phone at
night
and this happened like probably a good
mile and a half away
whatever
whatever so somebody let the house on
fire so that that was
that was interesting you know it was
funny my mother-in-law was hilarious but
she was just like
saying
something to the effect
that the she'd wish the person did that
later on
during the fireworks show because none
of the fireworks could could follow
basically somebody lighting their house
on fire that was like way more exciting
then then you went back to the fireworks
it's just like yeah you know
it's kind of like doing your closing
joke in the middle of your act you know
what i mean
it's kind of like god
i don't know what the [__] else it's
like
so anyways um
do you think would have been rude of me
if i i live right next to him and i put
on ac dc houses on fire
this house is on fire you know as their
house was on fire
you know talking heads burning down the
house with that would that be obnoxious
i think it would be
what is the proper music to play when
your [__] neighbors light their house
on fire what is the respectful thing to
do
is there is there some country song
saying i'm sorry your trailer's on fire
i don't [__] know i don't know this
is the monday morning podcast everybody
and uh like i said i'm doing it sunday
night and
i don't have my um
i don't have any advertising yet so i'm
just going to pause here because i'm
going to drop this [__] in
after i uh after i record this [__] so
with that this is the monday morning
podcast and here's a couple of
advertising ditties for you
and uh we'll be back after these
messages from me in the future
hulu plus everybody
you've probably tried hulu on your
computer but you know what hulu plus is
so much more
with hulu plus you can watch current
season episodes of your favorite shows
like modern family the daily show and
scandal and watch every episode of shows
like nashville lost and doctor who
you get ad free movies and kid shows too
now more than ever there's so much to
watch take total control with hulu plus
to stream these shows and thousands more
as much as you want wherever you want
hulu plus works on your computer your
smartphone roku apple tv xbox
playstation pretty much any streaming
device you already own you can even
watch on your phone or ipad while on the
train at work at the dentist or in the
bathroom you can even block off a day to
binge you also get access to originals
that you can't get anywhere else check
out the new show deadbeat a comedy about
a pot smoking guy who talks to ghost
binge on all 10 episodes starting april
9th for only 7.99 a month get your shows
anytime anywhere that's like only a
quarter a day everybody come on right
now sign up on huluplus.com bill or
click on the banner on my website and
get two weeks full access completely
free that's a whole extra week that's a
whole extra week more with the special
offer when you sign up at hulu plus dot
com slash bill so get with it and start
streaming tv now with hulu plus
all right and i'm back
hey huh how about those reads was i good
or what
ah [__] you i suck every week
but whatever i'm
trying so let's get down to brass tacks
let's talk about what what went on this
week i was in las vegas
um i boozed it up
and then i immediately went back on the
wagon and i've been able to hold out i
had one bear had one bear last night
that was it
and um
but i'm definitely going to stay back on
the wagon because i don't want to
[__] uh
you know i don't have a big booze head
again i'm gonna have to go through all
that [__] trying to lose the [__]
way you got it you got to [__]
you got to keep it in check you know
i've been telling this story on stage
and it's kind of bombing so maybe it's
it's better for the podcast you know i
was [__]
driving right and i stopped at a red
light you know four-way stop
so the person to the right of me you
know he's got the green light and he
makes a left in front of me and he was
so [__] fat he like leaned
his head
right down to his man boob and his arm
out the window kind of holding on to the
car
as he was picking the turret
so basically he wouldn't roll over and
[__] crush his passenger
i mean at what point do you just say all
right
i guess it really is like a drug addict
i mean you see a [__] drug addict
laying in the goddamn street
going over and taking a dump on a
[__]
i don't know what shrub
at what point do you like like dude i i
sleep on a sidewalk and i [__] outside
before you like hey you know what maybe
i uh
uh you know kind of knocked down the
whole [__] heroin use
maybe ought to take it down a few
notches
i i don't there's only a few things i've
seen like that
i saw this fat guy in seattle one time
he walked by me and he was gradually
picking up speed with the momentum of
his [__] weight and he went by me and
i felt this wind
it was unreal it really is like i really
is a [__] drug
um
i really believe that i didn't before
but i can tell you uh
just go veggie for two days man
that's like the uh what's that [__] that
what's that [__] the methadone or
something that gets you off to heroin
don't listen to me i know what the [__]
i'm talking about
um
so anyways back to vegas so we had the
monday off
me bartnik lawhead and versi and uh
so we want to bet on something we're
bored shitless there's nothing to bet on
so we ended up betting on me bartnik and
verzi bet on albania
to beat the
the germans i think they're playing
germany i don't [__] know and we sat
there we put money
on albania to win i put 100 bucks on
them to win and then i put 25 bucks down
on a tie it was basically one one two
two zero zero or nil nil as they say
after 90 minutes i went so i don't think
i've ever been that interested in a
[__] soccer game
in my life
and i'm telling you i learned the secret
to all americans who don't give a [__]
about world cup soccer if you want to
give a [__] put a hundred bucks on the
on the underdog you will find yourself
sitting on the edge of your seat i got a
picture of us
sitting there in the casino
and we our eyes you would think we were
watching the final two minutes of a
[__] super bowl and joe montana's got
the ball that's how much we were
watching this [__] and in the beginning
when albania is we thought scored
we thought they scored we lost our
[__] minds we jumped up
right there was all these other people
who were from albania and they got such
a kick out of the fact that these three
white dudes were absolutely losing their
[__]
you know that albania scored
well yeah now clearly we they would
think well how come they're not for the
the whities there in germany
um but of course this unbelievable pass
this guy had an unbelievable header
and the [__] ball goes into the net
we lose our mind
right the guy did a one-timer with his
head
we go [__] nuts like we're watching
the stanley cup playoffs and guess what
guess what it was offsides
can you believe it
i can't [__] believe it it was
[__] offsides
it's always offsides
it's always f i tweeted that
it's one thing i've learned about world
cup soccer anytime it gets exciting that
means it's offsides the amount of
[__] times
and how the defensive line could just
stop
and then make you offline start running
your [__]
i have to slow down because you slowed
down
i swear to god
i swear to god man if i had enough money
to start a soccer league i would teach
the world how to play that [__] game
and i would get just the same way the
nhl got rid of the [__] red line
that [__]
i put a [__] blue line out there just
like in hockey
all right
and once you're in the [__] zone
that's it if somebody can run faster
than you then guess what
he's going to take a nice [__] shot
at that goddamn goal that's as big as a
[__] house and we're going to start
having some nine to eight games
for bastards running around for eight
miles
to have a game be nothing to nothing
sure i won 105 bucks
i want something like that i think i
ended up being up 20.
i lost 100 on albania to win but i i got
the tie this is how [__] dumb we were
when it went into extra time and germany
scored the goal
we were like ah [__] and we got up and
we walked out
and everybody else was sitting there and
i'm thinking like ah they must be
waiting to watch the next game
and then we go up to the pool took a
steam went out to the [__] pool
just acting like idiots i kept
introducing paul verzi every woman that
would walk by be like excuse me matt
miss ma'am ma'am
just want to let you know new jersey's
own paul verzi i just thought you you
should know
that he is in your presence right now
and i swear to god for some reason that
was working
um
but anyways so we end up having we're
drinking like [__] pina coladas
i don't think i've ever had a pina
colada in my life but it just made sense
it's like 108 degrees out and it's like
that drink is mostly ice and it has an
umbrella maybe i can hold it over my
nose and try not to get a sunburn there
so i'm drinking that [__] and afterwards
later on that night we're getting
hammered at some bar and we start
watching the highlights
of albania waiting to see that goal that
didn't count and then see the german
goal and the extra time that we thought
ended it and we're sitting there
watching it in germany scores
and then albania scores and then germany
scores
ends up being two to one we're like wait
a minute what the [__] happened here
this is still the same this is a game
from earlier earlier this this season
what the [__] is this
i guess with the extended time it just
kept keeps going
we thought it was like sudden death the
first guy who scores wins so we [__]
walked out i mean it didn't change our
bet at all but now the looks on the
people's faces when we got up and walked
out it made a lot more sense to sort of
look up confusion like where are they
going
where are those fun-loving americans
that flipped out more than we did
where the [__] are they going so
so i learned that
i still think it's a great game i know
i've [__] all over but it's just fun
it's fun annoying people from other
countries
you know i enjoy the game all right uh i
do find it extremely confusing i find
the uniforms unbelievably [__]
confusing
okay like
i was sitting there uh
i don't know where the [__] i was in the
netherlands versus costa rica's on
all right
i've been to both places i got treated
great in both places so i'm like who the
[__] do i root for and then i find out
that costa rica is the underdog so i'm
like all right i'll go with the underdog
the costa ricans right
and then i'm sitting there i'm trying to
figure out which team is which
okay because
they both have like red white and blue
flags as far as i know but like one team
is wearing [__] orange
all orange
and i'm like i don't know who the [__]
is who i'm looking at the uniforms i'm
trying to find a flag and finally what
you got to do is you got to racially
profile them to figure out who the [__]
is you know and then you know
there's always going to be a couple of
black dudes or something like that
somebody with a tan
so it's going to throw you off
when you're going like okay he looks
like he he looks like he's from the
netherlands he looks like he's from
another ah that guy looks like he's from
africa
i don't [__] know
then he got to sit there for 90 minutes
and wait till somebody scores and see
where the [__] number goes to figure
out who the hell's who
it wasn't that bad took me but it
honestly took me a good like a minute
and a half two minutes to figure out who
the [__] was who
i don't think that's right and i don't
like that creepy moment too where they
hold hands with children and walk out
all right
there's been too much coverage of
[__] uh pedophiles and that type of
stuff as an american in my country
they got everything they've made kids
weird you know you don't touch them you
don't go near them you don't hold their
[__] hands
okay i guess it makes it safe because
everybody's looking but it's just it's
really [__] creepy you know
taking their hands and you're walking
them out onto the pitch that's like when
you're in a titty bar you're dumb enough
to go get the private dance she takes
you by your hand she walks you out in
the back it's just it's [__] creepy
you don't do that all right
you don't have them run through
fountains in public either with no shirt
on okay they want to do that [__] you do
it in the backyard
okay that's your kid okay
[__] turn on that little [__]
sprinkler in the back have the kid run
through that [__] you don't bring them
down to the goddamn mall like they do in
columbus ohio whenever i do the funny
bone out there it's a bunch of [__]
little kids doing a [__] wet t-shirt
concert
um contest right i swear to god if i was
if i were
if i worked for the special victims unit
that's where i would park my ass on a
slow week
and i would just look for somebody
enjoying that [__] a little bit too much
[Laughter]
um
so anyways so that was the deal i made
money on roulette i made money
twice i made money uh throwing dice
i made money on the tie of albania
i wasn't betting big but i would just i
would i would lose a little early and
then i would win and then i just walked
away and i was [__] done
so i think in the end i i probably
made somewhere between two and 300 bucks
that was about it
that was about it right
and uh other than that i haven't been
doing [__] all week i'm trying to forget
my last hour hour and a half of material
i went out last night i did a little bit
of stand up
i got a i got one new
[__] five minute block
starting over again
i don't know i got nothing i got nothing
i don't know what the [__] to tell you
um
what else did anybody uh
anybody watch the uh the ufc last night
that erickson guy whatever the [__] his
name is
fought uh benicio del toro
what was the benicio del toro head with
brad pitt's torso from fight club
um
first three rounds were kind of boring
and then it got
then it got good
it got really [__] good and ronda
rousey ronda rousey over the [__] you
say her name she [__] uh
dude she beat up the chick that she was
fighting the way my older brother used
to beat me up
you know i'd get a couple in and then he
just put me in a headlock throw me over
his hip and then just give me a bunch of
noogies except there was no there was no
ref to break it up
i was actually upset when the referee
broke it up and i didn't realize that
her arm had gone limp
jesus christ she took like seven punches
right to the forehead you know what's
funny about the ufc
like you just can't [__]
you can never get over there quick
enough
at least in boxing when you get [__]
knocked out you go down and the guy goes
to the other corner in that sport they
rush you when they [__] what does it
what that what that did
bang it and banging and banging and the
[__] ref is coming over like no
you always take like another three four
i don't know haven't said that i still
love the sport
and uh verzi always gives me [__]
he [__] texted me last night he goes
uh
i texted him i said hey i'm watching
that sport you love because he's always
[__] on it i'm watching the ufc
and he said uh he goes i'm watching it
too
and he goes uh he goes i like the ufc i
just think boxing is better and i texted
him back i was like yeah i kind of
guessed that the first 18 times you told
me that
he's one of those guys who always hypes
up boxing is like the sweet science
whoever called it the sweet science
first i don't think ever got [__]
knocked out
[Laughter]
you know
whoever called it this sweet science
never talked to a boxer that's in his
50s and 60s and is dealing with the
[__] brain trauma
i mean i totally respect boxing and
you're sick i i think you know they're
[__] warriors
but um
i just hate people who attack the ufc
and they just yeah they're [__]
rolling around the ground it looks like
two guys about ready to [__] each other
it's just like i understand that a
little bit
who's getting who the guard is basically
missionary position
except somebody's trying to [__] you
know
knock your [__] block off other than
that
i guess it's uh
i guess it is a sexual position
but um
i will say this people who just always
say that you know dude if they went up
against a box or a boxer with blah blah
blah blah blah i don't think so i think
it's like 50 50. because i remember when
uh
was it tim the maniac sylvia fought that
what the [__] was that guy's name he had
like the hardest head ever
and he tried to grab him by the back of
his neck and pull him down and [__]
give him a knee to the head and the guy
just threw an uppercut and knocked out
tim sylvia i think it would be about 50
50.
but i would have to get after a while i
would think the ufc guys
would learn to deal with the danger of a
boxer's hands because i don't think
anybody in the ufc can box as good
as a professional boxer because that's
all they [__] do
you know what i mean like i'm sure
there's some quarterbacks in the nfl
that can kick the ball
you know
can actually do a halfway decent punt
but they're not going to be better than
the punter who sits there stretching his
[__] leg until he can do a total
split they're never going to kick it
farther than that guy because that's all
he does so i would think even muhammad
ali in his [__] prime
would have a hard time going 50 50 if
all he knew was boxing
because i would think
that 50 of the time
maybe he could catch the person as they
came in and tried to shoot his legs and
i know i don't know [__] about this all
you fight fans [__] relax all right i
got an hour here to kill this is me just
you know i took a couple of [__]
jiu-jitsu classes and that was it before
i was on to something else i was just
like this this isn't for me
you know what i mean
by the time i by the time jiu-jitsu
became
people were doing it i was already in my
30s and i was just like i'm too [__]
old
to be [__] rolling around the ground
you know i'm giving up my wallet okay
i'm at that age and i'm gonna pray you
don't kill me
take whatever you want man i don't want
trouble i got a black belt in that so
anyway just just [__] entertain me
here i would think
that if a you a a mixed martial artist
instead of a ufc guy or woman if they
were to [__]
fight a professional boxer obviously you
know
they're throwing hands
so all i would do i would stay outside
if i had an mma person skill i would
stay outside of their hands and i would
just do what joe rogan loves the best
the [__] leg kicks
and just keep smacking him in the
[__] thigh
over and over and over again chop them
down
and then when you shoot their legs the
second you get them on their back
they're [__] if you have no if you
have no [__] defense
against somebody that knows how to
grapple and ground up on the ground dude
you're [__] done
it's over
maybe i'm nuts maybe i'm [__] crazy i
don't know anything about this but i'll
tell you this right now i was actually
those uh the women
of the ufc
um
like what's her face ronda rousey what
she did to that woman she could do to me
i mean it would be over
she'd [__] throw my pasty ass right
over her goddamn hip
my [__] powder white legs would slam
on the ground
and i would i don't know what anyone
then i would just be taking him to the
[__] head
i'd probably be making some really
embarrassing like emasculating [__]
noise in her armpit like
and that would
then i would lose consciousness
i think if i ever dated somebody i was
married to a woman that was as good a
fighter
as rhonda is i would literally the
amount of times
i would be like okay okay you know just
let's just talk this out
all right
just
because you could she would literally be
beating the [__] out of me what am i
going to do am i going to report it
i couldn't then what i'd have to do is
on the side
i would have to start taking some
classes
just as a man i can't [__] report
this [__] i'd have to start taking some
classes to somehow get some sort of
defense
against her throwing me across the
[__] living room
and then once the first time
she ever saw any sort of beyond what the
[__] i knew
you know or were you taking classes
behind my back and then she kicked the
[__] out of me even worse
oh my god see this is why i wish the
chappelle show was still on how funny
would [__] dave
chappelle be in a goddamn sketch
about
dating the ufc female champion and
pissing her off
remember in the rick james sketch when
he gets kicked in the air and he landed
on that dresser just imagine them using
the same special effects of him getting
thrown over
that one of those judo throws
jesus christ
that reminded me of of when i i remember
in the late 80s
um
when you used to [__] like her fight
her her title defense that reminded me
of tyson
in his prime as far as how quickly it
was over
do you remember that [__] anybody else
of age that they remember ordering the
tyson fight guys come on over i got the
tyson fight and like
tyson the fight ended before the pizza
got there
and everyone was just standing around
[__] eating a pizza that was too hot
to bite into
just going like dude that was [__]
[__]
cost like 45 bucks
i still remember where i was when uh
when he beat michael spinks a buddy of
mine we were in his newly finished
basement
um the same basement i watched when
larry bird stole the ball from isaiah
thomas
and had a nice low ceiling i remember
that i jumped up and scraped my knuckles
like raising arizona
um i remember we were we were there
watching the fight
and uh
we were beside ourselves couldn't
[__] believe it because we didn't
understand back then
you know the whole [__] liver punch
and all that [__] we just didn't get it
we were like how the [__] is this guy
actually i think he took one to the head
at that point took a shot to the side
and then in the last he had already gone
down like [__] three times over in
like 90 91 seconds
and we were pissed it was funny his
house was the house that always ordered
the fight
i watched like the first wrestlemania
over there
god damn it those were good times
good [__] time so anyways um i still
totally respect uh boxing i respect all
of that [__] man i wish i knew how to do
that stuff i wish i could learn that
[__] without getting the brain damage
you know
um so anyways what do you guys think
if floyd mayweather because that's the
thing versi always brings up
oh dude we had a [__]
we had a [__] epic
argument
where where verzi was trying to say
i'm going to get him in trouble here
because everyone's going to [__]
write into his podcast he was trying to
say that mayweather
would have beaten hagler
hearns duran
and sugar ray leonard and i was trying
to say look
you know at best he goes two and two
okay
i'm not trying to disrespect him and i'm
not trying to disrespect them
and verse he just kept going he's the
fastest fighter ever that's what they
said he has the fastest hands
ever
it's like okay okay yeah the guys
calling the fight who are selling the
fight who are trying to convince you
that you are not wasting your money by
ordering the pay-per-view yes they're
hyping him up is the greatest the
fastest and all that [__] [__]
but uh you know
i don't know
so me lawhead and him got into screaming
matches bartnik sat there laughing at us
we were in this great steakhouse at the
mirage
unbelievable [__] steaks
unbelievable [__] steaks we had and
uh
we were like it was us
and there was one other family that was
like across the restaurant we basically
closed the place down and we got into
such a [__] screaming match
about whether or not hagler
hearns or whatever could beat floyd
mayweather i remember looking over and
there was two waiters at the other side
of the restaurant just laughing at us
but uh verzi was convinced
that uh
mayweather
i don't know
i gotta be honest with you i don't watch
enough boxing to know i mean i don't i
don't see mayweather knocking anybody
out
uh i don't know i always thought hagler
was the best out of all of them even
though he lost to sugar ray leonard i
thought that was [__] i thought he
won that fight
and uh i gotta hand it to him
he [__] lost that fight said this is
[__] he left he moved to italy
he became an action hero right
and now he never heard of him since i
bet his brain is pretty much intact so
good on him
you know bartnik is convinced that he
[__] threw the fight and that's why
he immediately went to italy afterwards
and became an action hero star he said
that didn't make any [__] sense
um
i don't know but he looked visibly upset
at the end of the fight he's saying like
this is why you don't fight vegas and
yadda and all those other [__]
[__] so anyways
um all right how far oh 41 minutes in
jesus christ uh i gotta hype a couple of
things here for this week um
i got uh i'm doing a benefit
for hungry children children who are
hungry um in brooklyn
next week we'll have the link up on my
twitter page at the mm podcast
and uh monday and tuesday i will be out
there doing a set
um
and uh
i guess out in brooklyn so i'll be back
in new york with that heat humidity and
all of that [__] horse [__] and uh
then i'm immediately flying right back
here because um yeah i'm on vacation
i'm on [__] vacation over here
um also i gotta ask some people if you i
already don't i don't know [__] about uh
fighting and that type of stuff
obviously from the last five minutes of
this podcast but i gotta ask you my dog
sometimes when we're hiking
i don't know if it's because she's hot
or what but all of a sudden she just
wants to eat every piece of grass
on the hike and she eats it until she
pukes i don't understand what the [__]
that is
um i bring water i offer her water she
doesn't want it
and she keeps eating the grass then she
pukes and then she's dehydrated then she
drinks the [__] out of the water so
basically what i've been doing is i've
been you know because these are the
hotter months i just decided i'm going
to take her on shorter hikes
earlier in the morning and i noticed you
know she wasn't doing a lot of that
trying to eat grass [__] so i can't tell
if she
you know just has a sensitive stomach i
don't know what's going on so if i
figure if i gave my two cents
about uh
fighting and i don't know [__] i might
as well listen to you [__]
weekend warrior dog whispers what the
[__] you think it is
i guess i could google it right
i don't [__] know
so anyways
what else the [__] did i want to talk
about
i think that that was it all right let
me do uh
let me do my last bit of reads here
on the podcast here for the uh for the
advertising for this week before i get
into it just remind everybody once again
if you'd like to donate to the podcast
without donating just go to uh
billboard.com
click on the podcast page and click on
the amazon link anytime you're gonna go
to amazon if you think you're gonna buy
something if you take that extra step i
get credit for sending traffic there and
they kick me a little uh thanks for
sending traffic here doesn't cost you
extra money it is an extra step if you
don't want to do it i get it but i'd
appreciate it if you would
um and with that here's some more
wonderful reads from bill burr in the
future
well hey guess what there was only one
ad read this week
um
so
back to the podcast you [__] cons
jesus christ did i butcher those or did
i not
i have no [__] idea
um last but not least all of a sudden
everybody's getting a drone
and i'm calling it right now
somebody with a drone is going to kill
somebody
they're going to take down a [__]
helicopter or a small [__] plane to
have just anybody in the world be able
to buy those things and fly them around
i cannot [__] believe that that is
legal
okay
no flight plan
no radio contact no pilot no nothing
just flying around up there
do you know when you ride in a
helicopter you're not allowed to have
anything in your pockets especially if
the [__] doors are off is anything a
cell phone anything goes into that
[__] rear rotor you immediately have
to put that [__] in neutral and auto
rotate down to the ground
okay can you imagine
what's gonna happen one of these [__]
drones i swear to god where the [__] is
the faa
on this one
i really hope they don't allow people
to get these things to the level that
they're going to get them what's funny
already is perverts are seeing the
advantage of them
and i've watched a couple youtube videos
and there's women that have accused
they've taken pictures of these guys
they're bringing these cameras up and
they're hovering outside of like uh
you know
these high-rise
apartments
trying to look into people's well this
is just going to be like
i swear to god in the future i literally
think everything is going to be filmed
you can have no [__] privacy
whatsoever
you're going to have to stay in your
house with the goddamn
shades drawn
and then someone will come up with some
technology some infrared see through the
shades
[__] app that people can use
for the love of god get a [__] life
if you want to get a pilot you want to
fly get the balls to get a [__]
pilot's license
[__] [__] you're going to fly that
thing around up there and almost you
know potentially kill somebody while
you're safe on the goddamn ground
i don't know that ain't right man ain't
right bill burr says it ain't right and
we're back um
all right he's what i got here let
listeners know that the all things
comedy has added good times with steve
simone
there you go or simone i don't know how
to say his name
um oh hey we had our first live part uh
our first live podcast last week where
we did an auction and all that i want to
thank everybody who called in
people who gave me [__]
and all that type of stuff we had a
great [__] time
um
and uh we're definitely gonna we're
gonna start doing one of those once a
month bringing on some of the stars of
the all things comedy network uh we're
having a great time running this network
it's a slow burn but slowly but surely
it is building momentum
and uh thanks to you guys for listening
to all the great podcasts that are out
there on the network so uh
keep listening all right and here we go
yoko ono add it again multiple emails
from people sending the following link
of yoko ono at the glastonbury festival
this summer
oh yeah i made fun of yoko on a long
time ago i got to be honest yoko i know
in the plastic band whatever plastic ono
band or whatever the band is [__]
great
and i gotta tell you as far as this
video for yoko ono her singing isn't
that bad she'd actually be pretty decent
at a uh
in a [__] karaoke uh thingamajig
there
i don't know if you want to see him some
more bad yoko ono or actually good yoko
owning oh no singing which is sort of
just bad singing
um all right let's get to the questions
for this week here uh summertime blue
hey there billy weedwacker
uh i'm sitting in my cubicle and i'm
hating my life it's summertime my kids
are hanging by the pool with my wife and
i have friends who have cooler jobs that
allow them more time off to travel and
hang out this rut well first of all dude
the fact that you have a wife and kids
at home and you got a cubicle job you
you're crushing it
you know i always thought those cubicle
job they gave you the little skinny
michael j fox tie and that's all you got
um anyways this rut has me thinking
about the good times i used to have
riding my bike playing baseball and
hanging out with friends all day till it
got dark and then playing some video
games once the mosquitoes got too bad
what are your favorite summertime
memories what do you miss the most
um
what do i miss the most
oh yeah you know what it is is she just
i just i just wish there was a way to
convey to a kid a mortgage
you know being in a relationship
uh property tax
you know nine to five job
term papers all of this [__]
that you have to do
counting calories all that [__] crap
i just wish there was a way that that
you know what i miss i miss
my problems that i had as a kid that i
thought were huge that's what i miss
you know
someone was picking on me at school
that there was some girl i liked that i
didn't know what to say
you know oh that the sunday papers are
coming and they're gonna be really heavy
when i go to deliver them those are my
problems oh it's raining today on my
paper route dude i had i had the [__]
i had the best
childhood
when i really go back and think about it
you know
i had a paper route so i always from
third grade on i had a paper i always
had a [__] job so i always had money
i used to make like like 18 bucks a week
okay when you don't have a car payment
you don't have a mortgage we don't have
to pay for food when you have zero
[__] expenses
and all you're into is [__]
candy bars and football cards eighteen
dollars
in a pack of football cards was 35 cents
a pack
and it came with a piece of gum
that was unbelievable we had this we
used to live in this old house
it was a uh we lived in the front and
these other people lived in the back it
was just beautiful
i mean it was run down but i mean you
could you could it's the reason why i
bought this old house that i have i had
the appreciation for the woodwork and
stuff
and um
when i i always thought was cool is it
had two stairways like a lot of old
houses have a stairway in the front and
the stairway in the back and i always
thought that that was cool as [__] but
what they did was they put dividers up
in the middle and built another kitchen
in the back and did the back stairway
was a smaller place and then the front
we had the bigger one because we have a
bigger family
and uh this [__] place
had
unfinished blair witch basement like one
of those turn of the century
last century i should say uh foundations
that always had the smell of dampness
and all of that [__]
that was downstairs
we had a ping-pong table which was just
an unfinished piece of plywood with a
net on it and the paddles right a bunch
of other [__] down there and spiders
we'd play that down there and you had
the washer and dryer down there which we
had up on two by fours because every
time it [__] rained it flooded down
there
um and the pump never worked like you
had to go down there and put on your big
[__] rain boots and turn on the pump
and
then on the next floor up
there was a dining room a living room
and a kitchen
and then you went up the stairs and the
woodwork the banister and all that was
[__] incredible
like i said it needed a little tlc but
then you went upstairs
and to the right was a bedroom and to
the left was two other bedrooms and then
there was another bathroom
and um
and then when you went through the
bathroom there was another door that led
up to a third floor that had two more
rooms up there like you didn't have to
crouch down was this old [__] house
but up there you know we didn't have any
ac in that house and the second floor
was bad enough and you got up on the
third floor and you like literally
risked
[__] heat stroke
and i was this incredible old house that
we rented for the majority of my
childhood and next to it had a this
giant field
and um
we used to go out there all summer
we played baseball
during baseball season
during the winter we played football
uh my dad put up a basketball rim and it
was funny he wasn't a sports guy and he
thought a regulation room was nine feet
so we had a nine foot
[__] basketball room
on a slanted [__] driveway
no wonder i sucked at that sport
um
yeah
we used to ride bikes
all of that [__] before video games and
the internet and all that you just went
outside climb trees we used to climb up
this [__] tree i lived in like 20
15 minutes south of boston
i don't know what it was i don't so we
probably like 10 12 miles outside the
city and when we used to climb up a tree
that was high enough that we could see
the potential building in the john
hancock building two biggest buildings
in uh
in boston you know both insurance
companies go figure right they never
[__] pay anybody
um
we used to climb all the way up those
[__] things
we we were a member of this this [__]
uh
town pool
we'd ride our bikes down there we just
staying out at the pool from one to
seven every [__] day
swimming all day just hadn't there's no
[__] words
your life was a vacation
it was [__] ridiculous and all you
had was this [__]
homework and i was such a [__] i
couldn't even get through
doing homework my life was a [__]
joke
my life has never been better
was it was never better and you just
don't even realize that when you didn't
have rent you had no [__] worries
sitting around eating [__] candy bars
you don't even get fat [__] hilarious
so that's what i miss i miss all of that
all of that [__]
those [__] uh elementary school days
right into like junior high once you
started getting into junior high then
that's when people really started to
break off into clicks people started
their first [__] drinking and drug
abuse and then all the [__] starts
and all that [__] crap that's what
kind of went off the rails for me um
but um
yeah man i miss all of that [__]
it's [__] perfect
dude when you don't have any expenses
and you're making 18 a week and your
hobby costs you 35 cents a whack i mean
it's you're the king of the world so i
yeah i miss all of that i miss all of
that [__] that's what i would say um let
me get to the questions jesus christ oh
i guess that was a question i got so
involved in that i forgot it was um all
right my friend is now a woman
oh jesus um
to he whose hair is red
and whose balls are blue
i'm a 25 year old man and one of my
close friends from high school who i
still see somewhat regularly recently
told me that he's he is transgender
you know i don't know what that means
let me look that up i always get trans
transvestite means you just wear women's
clothes
let me get this right transgender
here we go transgender according to
wikipedia
is the state of one's gender identity
self-identification as woman man neither
or both or gender expression not
matching one's assigned sex
oh so you don't have to get a uh so a
transsexual then as if if you had the
sex change
you know what this is like this is like
trying to spell like
psycho psychology psychosic
psycho psychotic i don't [__] know
all those ph p y s c h all those [__]
things i can never keep them straight
um
identification by other
by others as male female or intersex
based on physical slash genetic sex
this is already over my head transgender
is independent of sexual orientation
sexual orientation what is that what is
sexual orientation what you're into
now i got to look on this right sexual
orientation is an enduring personal
quality and inclines you people to feel
romantic or sexual attraction
to persons of the opposite sex or gender
the same sex all right so basically gay
straight
by okay
so that mystery
oh my god this is like quicksand it just
keeps going further
transgender is independent of
who you want to [__] let's put this in
layman's term
transgender
people may identify as heterosexual
homosexual
bisexual
pansexual
polysexual or asexual i know what
asexual is i know a bisexual
what is pansexual
why would you have a little baby
pansexual or omnisexuality
is sexual attraction sexual desire
romantic love or emotional attraction
toward people of any sex
or gender identity
oh so that's not bisexual like you're
into men and women
this goes to the next level where
you're also into transsexuals
jesus you know what this this seems like
you know those word problems and math
oh my god look at this you know what
this [__] okay polysexual
it looks polysexual you know you know
the male sign in the female sign the
sign for polysexual looks like that sign
that prince changed himself to
polysexuality is the attraction to
multiple genders
and or sexes
what do they mean multiple genders
there's there's two genders you they're
a man or a woman right
or a transsexual
i'm already lost is that considered a
gender a polysexual if you run for
office do you have to know this [__] so
you don't [__] this up
president burr how much does a dozen
eggs cost i don't [__] know i got a
private chef
a polysexual person is one encompassing
or characterizing
characterized by many different kinds of
sexuality polysexuality is a sexual
identity used by people who recognize
that the term bisexual
i can't even read this word
r-e-i-f-l-e-s
the gender dichotomy that underlines the
distinction between heterosexuality and
homosexuals oh is that what it is
i have no i don't [__] i don't even
know all right so
jesus [__] christ
you know what's funny the amount of
people that could read that and totally
get it i i just it just all becomes
[__] mumbo jumbo to me
all right i can't even remember
transgender
okay he actually said this means that
even though he is a physically a man he
identifies as a woman okay he told me
that he isn't thinking about getting
surgery or anything major like that but
wants to try living as a woman from now
on
well he just became way more difficult
to buy for didn't he
[Laughter]
guys are easy to buy now what do you buy
the guy who identifies as a woman that
has everything you know what do you get
them
some chanel scarf
that's out of print i don't [__] know
anyways he has always been a little
peculiar so this didn't exactly come out
of left field but since telling me this
he she has begun wearing unflattering
women's clothing that to be blunt look
[__] gross
well i bet did he know how to dress when
he was a guy i mean can you give him a
little bit of a learning curve
how would you put together an outfit
i would go with yoga pants and flats i
would just start like you know i would
dress like a woman on laundry date i
would ease myself into it you know
before i tried to pull off anything a
little more risky
you know
like what would i change my name to
whatever wilma
wilma's clubbing tonight
then what do i do
you know you know i have to do some sort
of theme like dressed like a housewife
in the 1950s
like rosie the riveter meets [__] uh
that chick who was banging desi arness
um
lucy
whatever i don't imagine david cross
prancing around in a skimpy miniskirt
anyways i want to be supported oh he
went he went yo he dove straight in
he's dressing like a [__] skank
anyways i want to be supportive of my
friend in this time in their life and
don't want to turn my back on them but i
don't know how much more i can handle
seeing them dress like this and his
slash her new interest in cutesy girly
stuff seems contrived
i've i don't think you can really
contrive something like that
you know it takes a lot of [__] balls
which i'm sure you can see hanging out
of that small skirt
[Laughter]
to walk around and that [__]
he says i've thought about suggesting
for him slash her to wear more
conservative female clothing but don't
know how to begin to bring up a subject
like that
uh i would just bring up barbara bush
and just see what the conversation goes
um
uh i don't know what the [__] to tell
you here from making suggestion now this
is a question do you have to call her
her
i think that's [__] weird it's like
you're clearly a dude you still have a
dick right
you know i i don't know i guess
that's one of those things we go like
yeah he's uh he's right over there and
then somebody like she
she's over there
people patting themselves in the back
how politically correct they are oh you
mean that hairy leg chick with the dick
and balls
is that where she is jesus [__]
christ two plus two is five now
i'm accepting with that with the with
his jean skirt isn't that enough
you're gonna come at me about pronouns
anyways overall this friendship is just
proving to be exhausting because i feel
like i've lost a friend i once had and
they've become a new person that i don't
get along with am i an [__] if i stop
agreeing to hang out with him slash her
and slowly cut them out of my life what
would you do in my situation he slash
she has always had a strong personality
and many other friends so it isn't like
i'd be leaving them to be alone but am i
a bad person if i can't handle being
their friend anymore thanks love the
podcast and go [__] yourself now if
somebody's being irritating they're
[__] irritating all right you've
accepted their choice
you know
i don't know if they're annoying the
[__] out of you then yeah
you seem like you've accepted that fact
like you can't go so liberal that even
though
they've become a douche that you're
going to completely ignore that because
you feel like you're now
not accepting the fact that he now
dresses like a she so if you don't have
a problem with that which you don't seem
to but the person still is annoying then
you know don't you can't just [__]
hang out with them because now they're
wearing a dress
you know treat them like a regular
person if they're [__] irritating you
got to cut them out of their life out of
your life
that's it all right corporations billy
ceo
you're always trashing corporations and
rightfully so but are there any
companies you do like
if you were a nascar driver who would
you want to be your sponsor or if you
did a commercial what would it be for go
[__] yourself and come back to baltimore
um
dude that's a great [__] question
i don't know i guess a beer company
because i like beer any sort of booze i
would be fine with other than that i
would like to try to get somebody uh
i don't know somebody that makes
furniture in this country country or
somebody who
uh don't know
[__]
redoes cars or some some that i thought
was cool but they weren't like i
certainly wouldn't want a walmart jesus
cleo
the [__] dog caller
who would i want i don't know i probably
like
some of the beer some of the obscure
beer companies that i've i found you
know like when i was in australia that
little creatures beer that i liked
um
i would say some [__] like that
i guess
i don't know the nhl
just [__] that i was into maybe a drum
company but they're not gonna waste
their time putting that [__] on the side
of a car would they
who the [__] would i have that's a great
[__] question something unique
i don't know you know i just like to go
out there independent
and just have a [__] badass car with
no sponsor name on it right and just as
sick as [__] paint job
make all those other guys look [__]
stupid right then if you actually win
you know
just have a [__] i don't know what
the [__] he'd put on it
some of that [__] you see on all those
cool car shows the gas monkey [__]
um
i guess something like that ah goddammit
this is like when he's back in the day
when you still had record stores i mean
i mean what makes cd stores when there's
virgin and all that [__] and you walk
around during the week i'm gonna buy
this cd and buy that cd in my
then you walk in the store and you
couldn't [__] remember anything i
might have to answer this one next week
all right i don't know
no [__] idea
all right engagement ring dear bill
matrimony
i'm buying my girlfriend an engagement
ring soon when i want to get something
simple i feel like giving her something
fancy will stress the importance of
luxury and that's not how i want to
start our lives together
jesus christ i do well and money is not
the issue i think that if i tied a
string around her finger that should be
enough it's a symbol not a collector's
item how do i convey this to her also
please don't act like a chick and tell
me how and why it's important to her
well i mean you've basically walled off
everything except your opinion you sound
very [__] controlling and you sound
like a cheap [__]
all right so go get her a [__] little
piece of string
and and convey to her the importance of
the dollar
do that for her everybody loves that you
know when you're throwing a keg party
for someone to come around go hey let's
get a cheap beer
okay
let's only get a quarter keg everybody
get a small sippy cup here
on this big day of celebration this is
the biggest day of her [__] young
life
the only day bigger than this is gonna
be when she gives birth to children
okay
so go ahead with your little string tie
it around her [__] finger ah how do
you say that to her
jesus [__] christ
how would you like it sir if once you
guys got married and you were going down
and you wanted to go down and you wanted
to go buy this new corvette that's
coming out the new [__] z06 whatever
it is it's gonna go 200 [__] miles an
hour and you earn the goddamn money and
she says no
and she stresses to you the importance
of that [__] [__] oh i guess you're
gonna say well it's my money i can do
what the [__] i want um
i don't know how to give an example um
all i can say is that i i feel bad for
this woman
because uh
i don't know
i don't know i feel like you feel the
right woman you want to [__] buy her
you know
i feel like if if you [__]
love your wife
okay and if you have the funds
don't you want her to have like a closet
full of all the shoes she ever wanted
you know that's like that's like her
sports package or whatever go ahead go
have all your [__] shoes dress up
i know you're into this [__] i know that
makes you happy why would i want to deny
you that
go get all the [__] shoes you want
you know
i know personally speaking i would buy
her a uh
i don't know i would buy this is what i
would do sir i would buy a ring that
conveys your feelings towards her rather
than your feelings towards your wallet
and you're concerned that she's going to
be spending all of your money
and if that really is a concern of yours
uh that's a major [__] concern
because that's one of the number one
things that drives people apart is money
if you guys are not on the same page
monetarily i would really reconsider
what the [__] it is you're about ready
to do
all right there all right there control
freak [__] cutting all the goddamn
jesus christ
all right this is my impression of this
guy
on one of his kids birthdays all right
they're all in the other room he's in
he's in the other room counting his
[__] money and they're in the other
room going happy birthday
to you hey keep it down
don't sing too loud don't be too happy i
don't want i don't want to set a
precedent with our baby's first birthday
that you know this is how happy we got
to be even more happy in the next one
give her give us some place to go
quit your crying
um all right
and that is the podcast for this week
everybody thank you so much for
listening
i uh appreciate everybody's listening
and all that type of [__] don't take any
crap go [__] yourselves
i will talk to you next week
and um
i think that's it yeah that is it all
right go [__] yourselves
you